ma question s'adresse à madame le
ministre de l'ancien entre
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
madame le ministre depuis plus de trois
mois des universitaires sont en grève en
france c'est le cas par exemple à
l'université de lille où certains
enseignants n'assurent pas leurs cours
depuis le 5 décembre
ces enseignants ne sont pas sereins
déclarer leur grève ce qui paralyse le
fonctionnement de l'université
la liste de leurs revendications et sans
fin même si la baisse des crédits
consacrés aux laboratoires de recherche
apparaît être le détonateur de leur
mouvement de contestation
ce sont les étudiants qui n'ont plus de
cours depuis plusieurs mois qu'ils m'ont
alertée je sais à l'heure qu'il est que
les étudiants ce sont à la fois inquiet
et en colère parce qu'ils ne sont plus
en mesure de recevoir l'enseignement
pour lequel ils se sont inscrits à
l'université
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer quelques
uns ici présents dans le public
d'autres collègues ont eu les mêmes
retour ces mouvements se répète au sein
de nos universités au détriment de la
formation de nos jeunes
la situation de l'enseignement supérieur
est particulièrement préoccupante
année après année nos universités ne
cesse de reculer au sein des grands
classements internationaux
si rien n'est fait les inégalités ventes
vont encore s'accroître entre les
étudiants
il y a ceux qui iront étudier dans les
grandes écoles ou à l'étranger et les
autres nos étudiants tous le droit à un
enseignement supérieur de qualité bien
sûr le niveau des examens finaux
s'adaptera au programme réellement
étudié par les étudiants mais accéder au
concours nationaux leur sera très
difficile voire inaccessible
l'ascenseur social qui était l'essence
même de l'université ne peut pas
fonctionner dans de telles conditions
madame le ministre quelle est la
position du gouvernement que l'on a peu
entendu sur le sujet avez vous quelque
chose à dire aux étudiants qui sont
privés de cours depuis quelques temps